Speaker 1: So before giving his completely
deranged CPAC speech, Donald Trump actually
took some questions, and there were actually
some interesting questions asked, and Trump
was visibly sweaty, disheveled.
He seemed confused by many of the questions,
but some of the questions were actually pretty
interesting.
And this one, it's this this.
This one would almost make you blush if Trump
answered it any other way.
Trump was asked, as many of you may have heard,
the president of Ukraine has stayed in Ukraine
and is fighting.
He's fighting in Ukraine, trying to repel
the Russian invasion.
And Trump was asked If you were in such a
situation, would you also stay and fight?
And it's like, of course he would.
Of course we would.
Trump would be the first guy out.
He'd say, Please evacuate me.
And Trump knows he can't say I would be fighting
because no one would believe it.
So even he has to kind of hedge.
It's pretty interesting.
Take a look at this one.
Speaker 3: And you know, he's not abandoning
his people, are he's saying and taking up
arms with his countrymen.
If you were in a similar situation as president,
would you take up arms like Zelensky?
Speaker 4: Well, you know, you never know
about bravery.
Some people think they're brave and they're
not brave, and other people don't think of
themselves as very brave and they step up.
You never know until you get tested.
Speaker 1: So tricky.
Even for Trump, it would be too much to say.
I would be out there with a rifle.
Absolutely.
And so he it's actually he has this moment
where he knows he can't say that.
Nobody would believe that.
I think we know the answer.
Trump would not be taking up arms like Zelensky.
Trump would be either in the bunker or in
another country altogether.
And listen, it's more likely Trump would give
away classified documents if he was in Zelensky's
position than he would stay and take up arms
and fight anybody.
Trump was then asked, and this was pretty
interesting.
What would you do differently on Ukraine than
Biden?
Because Trump saying Biden's doing everything
wrong?
And Trump says, I guess for security reasons,
he doesn't want to tell you what he would
do differently.
Speaker 2: Well, I'll tell you what I would
do things.
But the last thing I want to do is say it
right now, because if somebody asks me that
is in a position where they can utilize whatever
it is, I give them, but I certainly wouldn't
want to be talking about right now.
Speaker 1: It's just not appropriate.
And of course, he has no idea of what he would
do differently.
He's just, he says it's Biden's fault, but
this is sort of like he's prepared to release
his health care plan soon, and he's going
to give us the vote evidence of voter fraud
soon.
It's all just around the corner.
Also, his infrastructure plan, then one oh,
now later in the interview.
And this is in a different moment.
Trump is asked about what?
What about this?
He actually does answer what one thing he
would do, and he says he would get Russia
out of Swift, the swift banking system, which
happened hours before this.
Trump apparently just didn't know that.
Speaker 2: Very, very important question to
be asked.
What is the one sanction or the two sanctions
that have not been implemented to stop Vladimir
Putin that you would implement given a Trump
presence sanctions now you have to just end.
Speaker 4: Sanctions are very expensive for
our country also.
But the one that people are talking about,
which is very, very severe, as you know, is
swift and that just really destroys the banking
system of a country.
It's a very big step and we'll see whether
or not that step is taken.
But thousands of people, hundreds of thousands
of people could die with this, and this could
spread to other countries and it could spread
throughout the world.
And this could be a world war.
Speaker 1: Yes.
OK, so so now Trump changing his tune and
saying this actually could become a world
war.
But at the time that he said, the one thing
that that you could look at doing is swift.
It had been done that it happened hours before
Trump apparently didn't know.
So those are the Trump interviews.
That's the Trump speech.
It was wacky.
We'll have some of these clips on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.
And then after the break, we'll look at the
non Trump craziness that happened
at CPAC.